messaging from the modern feminist
movement is you don't need a man they
want you to feel that your life would
not be enhanced by that decision to have
children would not be enhanced or
modified or changed for the better by
that decision to get married because
they want you single they want you
single on birth control they want you
promiscuous they want you prioritizing
career over marriage they want you
delaying to the point where then the
fertility you know sinks and they want
you to press because then that depressed
woman becomes Pharma dependent it's like
a win for them for the Matrix on all
fronts
thank you
[Music]